how's it going bros my name is peter pan
today we're going to do the charlie
charlie challenge because you bros just
won't
shut up about it it's obviously fake
it's so stupid for those who don't know
it's kind of like a ouija board except
more
except more lame basically some little
mexican kid died
and he became the spirit of this ouija
board
and he will answer your question if you
ask it charlie charlie
so let's try this out charlie charlie
what's the square root of five
oh my god
it charlie's [ __ ] stupid
everyone knows the square root of five
is two point twenty three
six seven zero six seven five five
all right let's try it again charlie
charlie
do i have genital herpes
there's obviously something wrong with
it and he keeps going to jets
yes let's try something different
charlie charlie
does my parents love me
the [ __ ] are you doing
[Music]
i i thought you thought what you're
making us look bad you [ __ ] idiot
i'm sorry just just go
go okay okay all right
square root of five is not yes you
[ __ ] idiot
all right no more hoax no more [ __ ]
honestly i just want to see if it works
so let's try it one more time properly
charlie charlie do people do this stupid
challenge on youtube
pretending they think it's real just for
more views
[Music]
oh my god look at that